quand j'étais petit il ya une phrase que
ma mère me répéter très souvent mais
sort un peu et encore scotché devant
l'ordinateur
cette phrase je crois que j'ai entendu
un bon milliard de fois et c'est vrai
faut comprendre ma mère son gamin et
elle a planté devant un écran pendant
des heures et il bougeait pas je sortais
pas je prenais pas le soleil et a levé
sa quête état de mon taux de vitamine d
chez pas assez fluide maman pourtant en
réalité j'étais tout sauf isolé j'étais
connecté à plus de monde que la
génération de mes parents ne l'avait
jamais été
je tissait des liens et je construisais
sans savoir les fondations de mon propre
avenir ce qui m'amène ici devant vous
aujourd'hui mon histoire
elle commence en 1999 j'ai 13 ans est
aussi loin que je me souvienne j'ai eu
un ordinateur à la maison commencé très
jeune pourtant à 13 ans je commence à
m'ennuyer
j'ai utilisé son ordinateur dans tous
les sens et maintenant je veux aller
plus loin je veux créer je veux créer
des logiciels
je veux créer des sites web alors du
coup mon premier réflexe c'est d'aller
en librairie chercher un livre pour
débuter dans la création de site web
alors j'arrive en librairie hélas hélas
je suis déçu parce que au dos de chacun
de ses livres il était écrit cet ouvrage
est destiné à des professionnels du
numérique et pour un débutant comme moi
bayh avait rien alors je me suis pas
arrêté là heureusement et j'ai choisi un
ses livres en fête
mes parents me l'ont offert pour noël
une année c'est le genre de cadeau noël
jamais recevoir et j'ai appris comme ça
j'ai appris à créer un site web
mais en lisant ce livre j'avais une
impression qui me revenait souvent
c'est que il était vraiment beaucoup
plus compliquée que ce qu'ils auraient
dû l'être
alors une fois le livre lu mon premier
réflexe a été de le réécrire de le
réécrire de la façon dont j'aurais aimé
l'apprendre je suis devenu un petit peu
schizophrène en fait je suis dit tiens
mathieu voilà ce qu'il faut que tu
saches d'abord tu commence comme ça a pu
ensuite tu fais ça et puis si ça te
paraît compliqué que ça met du temps
inquiète pas ça va le faire ça va venir
secours gelé mis en ligne gratuitement
ouverts à tous et c'est comme ça qu'en
99 le site du zéro était né c'était un
site ouvert à tous nos départs
évidemment il y avait personne y avait
juste des amis à moi
sauf qu'ils ont parlé à leurs amis qui
en ont parlé à leurs amis et 17 ans plus
tard
aujourd'hui le site est toujours en
ligne j'ai jamais lâché la faire alors
certes il a changé de nom il s'appelle
au penthouse rooms aujourd'hui il ya en
ligne plus de 1000 cours rédigé par une
communauté de passionnés
chaque mois plus de 3 millions de
personnes dans le monde viennent se
former sur ce site
3 millions c'est beaucoup et quand je
rencontre des gens qui sont venus sur le
site ce qui me disent en général c'est
évidemment que ça leur a permis
d'apprendre ça leur a permis de
comprendre mais aussi que ça leur a
permis de trouver un travail voire même
pour certains un but dans la vie on a du
mal à imaginer l'impact que cela peut
avoir sur la vie de tous ces gens alors
je vous propose une petite anecdote qui
m'est arrivé il ya quelques années
j'étais en train de faire les courses de
noël la veille de noël à la dernière
minute comme d'habitude et là il ya un
jeune qui me reconnaît dans la rue
il s'approche de moi il faire je vous
remercie beaucoup parce que c'est génial
j'ai vraiment tout appris grâce à vous
c'est génial merci merci merci beaucoup
moi je fais pas de rien super et puis
ensuite il fait bouger parce je vais
vous en faire quelque chose je revient
bougez pas pour moi j'attends quelques
minutes et effectivement le jeune était
un africain qui venait étudier en france
il avait appris
en ligne sur le site ce qui a permis de
venir en france et il était aussi
livreur de sushis se sont en libre et du
coup c'est comme ça qui m'a offert deux
gros sacs de sushis la veille de noël
et c'est aussi pour ça que dans ma
famille cette année là on a mangé des
sushis de noël gérant beaucoup de chance
parce que j'ai découvert très tôt ce que
j'aimais faire j'aime enseigner pourtant
encore aujourd'hui quand je dis que
j'enseigne et quand j'enseigne en ligne
les gens me regardent bizarrement parce
que pour les gens enseigner c'est un
truc sérieux ça se passe dans une salle
de classe avec un prof qui a le savoir
sur un estrades et qui diffuse son
savoir à une assemblée d'élèves qui
prennent sagement des notes
c'est comme ça qu'on enseigne
aujourd'hui et c'est aussi comme ça
qu'on enseignait il ya plus de 200 ans
vous avez ici une gravure du cnam qui
après 200 ans et qui montre finalement
qu'il n'y a pas tellement différence par
rapport à la salle de classe
d'aujourd'hui pourtant les choses ont
changé le monde a changé
la technologie aujourd'hui elle est
partout mais pas dans la salle de classe
et honnêtement quand elle y arrive des
fois c'est pire on parachute des
tableaux numériques interactifs ou des
ipad dans les mains des élèves et on
leur dit tenez apprenez grâce à ça vous
serez plus intelligents mais c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche c'est pas comme
ça que ça marche
la technologie ce n'est qu'un outil
c'est le tableau c'est la craie la
technologie elle est formidable et
dangereuse à la fois tout comme la
maîtrise du feu avait été formidable et
dangereuse à la fois tout dépend de
l'usagé qu'on en fait aujourd'hui je
considère qu'on en est à la préhistoire
de la technologie dans l'éducation
quand des gens vont en ligne à prendre
il pensa première fois qu'ils vont aller
sur des vidéos youtube en boucle et
c'est vrai une partie de la pédagogie en
ligne ça se passe comme ça il ya des
gens qui regardent des vidéos ils
apprennent mais ceux qui sont allés
récemment sur des formations en ligne
savent que ça va beaucoup plus loin
non seulement vous pouvez vous inscrire
à un parcours de formation complet qui
vous amène vers un métier mais en plus
ces parcours aujourd'hui sont reconnus
reconnu par l'état par les entreprises
et vous donne des diplômes strictement
équivalents à ceux des formations
classiques et en plus de ça vous êtes on
continue
accompagné par un mentor le mentor qui
sait c'est un expert du secteur un
professionnel est à bien des égards
c'est aussi un psychologue
c'est quelqu'un que vous allez voir par
visioconférence une fois par semaine ont
privé la première fois il va vous
demander
salut qui tue et qu'est ce que tu fais
dans la vie c'est quoi ton objectif pour
la formation
et puis ensuite il va essayer de deviner
votre niveau
il va ensuite vous donner les objectifs
du genre li secours pour la semaine
prochaine et essayer de faire cet
exercice
et vous pendant une semaine vous allez
travailler vous allez travailler vous
allez essayer de faire ce qu'on vous a
demandé si vous avez des difficultés
vous allez communiquer avec d'autres
élèves sur les forums sur les tchats
jusqu'à arriver à faire l'exercice et au
bout d'une semaine vous allez retrouver
votre mentor par visioconférence à
nouveau il va faire le point avec vous
alors comment ça s'est passé
et à partir de là il ya deux
possibilités soit vous avez tous réussi
sans problème
l'allemand torse en en compte et dhiba
super mais on peu accéléré pour pas
perdre de temps on avance au contraire
si vous avez des difficultés là le
mentor va prendre du temps pour vous
réexpliquer ou va vous ramener vers des
exercices d'un niveau plus simple pour
vous puissiez solidifier vos bases
c'est ce qu'on appelle de l'adaptive
learning ce que je trouve formidable
avec le mentorat c'est que de nombreuses
barrières sont en train de tomber les
barrières géographiques
évidemment parce que ici un français
peut mentor et un suisse
un suisse peu menteur et un marocain un
marocain mentor et un canadien
mais ce sont aussi les barrières de
l'âge qui sont en train de tomber
regarder un petit peu la diversité des
élèves qui viennent se former et parmi
eux
prenez par exemple karim qui est le
mentor de florentin père de deux enfants
en reconversion dans le développement
web ou encore stéphane 51 ans qui est
professeur dans une école d'ingénieurs
par ailleurs et qui est le mentor de
justin agronome de formation en
reconversion dans la gestion de projets
et ça marche
en six mois jean qui était en procédure
de licenciement chez psa a réussi à
rebondir et à créer sa propre société de
développement d'applications mobiles
pourtant malgré tout ce côté apparemment
miraculeux on n'a rien inventé
dès les années 80 un célèbre chercheur
en éducation
benjamin bloom avait découvert une
technique de formation extrêmement
efficace la plus efficace qui ait réussi
à trouver à ce jour elle combine deux
techniques une technique dite de
mastering dans laquelle l'élève ne va au
niveau supérieur que si la maîtrise est
vraiment le niveau inférieur
ce qui paraît évident mais ce n'est pas
toujours ce qui arrive dans la salle de
classe et une technique de mentorat
privé combinés ces deux techniques et
benjamin s'est rendu compte de résultat
absolument étonnant alors que dans une
salle de classe
les notes des élèves sont en moyenne
répartis comme ça en combinant ces deux
techniques
benjamin a observé que les notes des
élèves étaient répartis comme ça
en moyenne un élève était meilleur que
98 % des élèves d'une salle de classe
classique 98% c'est beaucoup je sais ce
que vous dites
ouais super c'est bien beau mais c'est
trop beau pour être vrai il ya forcément
dit sous roche
et vous avez raison il ya anguille sous
roche
c'est que le mentorat privé eh ben ça
coûte cher et donc dans les années 80
benjamin blum était bien embêté parce
qu'il disait
le mentorat privé c'est super mais ça
coûte trop cher il faut que je trouve
une autre solution qui soit aussi
efficace et c'est devenu un problème en
éducation très célèbre le bloom stoud
sigma problème qui n'a jamais réussi à
résoudre
jamais mais aujourd'hui grâce aux
technologies on peut mettre en relation
un élève avec son mentor beaucoup plus
rapidement beaucoup plus efficacement
pour beaucoup moins cher
est ce qu'il faut bien comprendre ici
c'est que seule la technologie n'aurait
rien résolu en combinant le bon
savoir-faire pédagogique avec le bon
savoir-faire technologique les
possibilités explose certains se disent
parfois que je suis peut être un
utopiste pourtant cette réalité je la
vis tous les jours et de plus en plus
d'élèves sont en train de se former
comme ça à mes yeux ce sont des
précurseurs qui vivent l'éducation de
demain et sont des gens qui m'inspirent
qui par exemple me pose des questions
comme rolly qui est à nos étudiants au
gabon qui un jour m'a demandé est ce que
ce serait possible d'être mis en
relation avec d'autres élèves de la même
région que moi et ça ça m'a fait
réfléchir
je me suis dit ce serait quand même
formidable que grâce à la technologie
rolly puisse rencontrer son voisin son
voisin à qui il n'aurait peut-être
jamais parlé en temps normal avec qui il
va trouver des intérêts communs et avec
qui va pouvoir communiquer et à prendre
or j'aimerais faire un voeu avec vous
aujourd'hui se veut ça serait que la
technologie ne sommes plus vue comme un
obstacle comme un objet nébuleux dont il
faut se débarrasser mais comme un
facilitateur et si au fond c'était ça le
but ultime de la technologie reconnecter
les individus pour pouvoir ensuite
enfin c'est facile totalement merci